gorgeous yes and we're probably going to
be in for some more of the snow on that
on those mountains out there I don't
know that what we're going to get this
weekend is going to be as heavy as that
couple of rounds of rain and snow that
we got at the beginning of the week but
we are looking to add a little bit more
gorgeous out there we got uh 12 about
two feet of snow in our local mountains
on Monday and Tuesday and some nice rain
around the lower elevations and a lot of
rain in the mountains too I think the
snow levels will be lower as we'll get a
little cooler weather coming in through
the weekend and into next week got a lot
of 30s out there with clear skies this
morning it is chilly so warm jackets for
sure for you and the kids this morning
freezing in Pahrump 39 Sandy Valley 30
in Indian Springs upper 30s for Mesquite
got those chilly 20s in Caliente even
teens in Ely freezing in Tonopah and
look for more Northerly breezes along
the River today it's 52 in Laughlin
North winds again could get up 25 30
miles an hour we'll be staying dry but
we'll see increasing clouds today a high
up around 60 degrees more clouds
tomorrow but we're really not looking
for the next round of rain for us here
in southern Nevada until Saturday mainly
Saturday afternoon and Saturday night
into early Sunday morning then I think
we'll get some sunshine for Sunday
afternoon before more rain on Monday and
Tuesday and again Mountain snow snow
levels could be down even around 5000
feet or lower this time rain snow wind
all that hitting really just far
Northern California into Washington and
Oregon and that's good news for Southern
California because they get another day
or two to dry out before the next round
of rain and snow some of those high
clouds already heading over the coast
though and we'll look for those to
increase for us through the afternoon
high today of about 59 degrees more
clouds tonight into Friday a little sun
tomorrow but more clouds than Sunshine
for your Friday and then those chances
of rain developing Saturday afternoon
Saturday night early Sunday and then
again on Monday and Tuesday so many
chances for rain again for us and
Mountain snow a